hey now the realm said Ford here good
thanks how do you want your video game
women to look more like real women from
hide on the female character proportions
are getting reeled in in Mortal Kombat X
so let's size it all up in this GS news
update the female fighters in the
upcoming Mortal Kombat X will be more
realistically proportioned than they
appeared in 2011's Mortal Kombat reboot
which was to say Kirby during a recent
twitch stream nether realms production
manager Spyro an agnostic oz explained
his approach to designing the lethal
ladies the mantra for this game has
always been realism heading towards a
more realistic look so the same thing
applies to the proportions where we try
to bring things back in per se to where
they should be another nether realm
developer said women will look more like
women do in the game exactly an agnostic
oz replied decide for yourself with a
new character model of katana versus her
2011 equivalent while changes aren't
vast she doesn't come across as having
overly exaggerated features by
comparison here's Molina from 2011
Mortal Kombat's
my my also during the livestream
NetherRealm revealed the alternative
design for scorpion and confirmed that
Jade will not appear in Mortal Kombat X
when it launches on April 14th on
current and last gen Xbox and
PlayStation as well as PC so do you see
much of a difference and do you prefer
having realistic character designs in a
game as ludicrous as Mortal Kombat also
when is it time we start dialing in the
man muscles in videogames making them a
little more realistic alright even lip I
left a list
you